hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start
warning spoilers ahead today
i'm going to explain a psychological
thriller movie called pet
the movie starts with a man who works at
an animal control department
his name is seth he is in charge of
feeding the dogs because he really loves
the animals there
on his way home he develops an obsession
with a woman named holly
he introduces himself while she is
writing a journal at first
holly forgets about seth who turns out
to be her schoolmate in high school
the next day seth asks nate who works as
a security guard at his office
he asks nate for advice and nate tells
him to be more confident and approach
her
shortly after his boss informs him that
the shelter's capacity is getting full
due to the increasing number of
abandoned animals
therefore one of the dogs has to be
euthanized so that the cage can be used
by other dogs
sadly he gives up one of his favorite
dogs to be killed
seth extensively researches holly's
online profiles to find any information
about her
the next day he goes to the restaurant
where holly works as a waitress
he tries to ask her out but she rebuffs
him
after work seth tails holly back to her
house
holly talks about the encounter earlier
with her friend claire
after a while she takes a drunken phone
call from her ex-boyfriend eric
who cheated on her holly receives a
large bouquet of roses at work the next
day
assuming they are from eric at the same
night she goes to the bar where eric
works to thank him for the gift
surprisingly eric says that he was not
the one who sent the flowers
holly who was confused by eric's words
decides to go out for a while
seth who has been following her all this
time suddenly asks her impression about
the flowers
hearing the answer from her seth denies
the statement that holly rejects his
love
leading to a physical confrontation eric
who sees the incident
straightaway beats seth up however seth
is able to steal holly's journal
he spends the next several days reading
every detail in the journal
as his performance slips at work seth
discovers a trapdoor to a basement in an
abandoned room of the animal shelter
where he sets constructing a steel cage
for several days ahead not only that
he takes some anesthetic and tries it to
find out how effective it is
he sneaks back into holly's house after
he finishes preparing all his equipment
eventually seth manages to kidnap holly
when she is about to go to sleep
he carries holly's body into the
basement that was found earlier using a
cardboard
after holly awakens in the cage she
tries to escape by removing the chains
that lock the cage
until her nails fall off not long after
seth comes to give her some food
nevertheless holly still refuses to eat
holly vows to survive she talking to
claire all night
at some point seth informs her that he
has heard holly talking in both her own
and claire's voice in the past
indicating that holly has personality
disorders he says that he loves her and
has imprisoned her to save her
he also reveals that he knows the truth
about her past from the journal
in a flashback holly discovered that
eric had slept with claire
and confronted her about it during a car
ride an angry holly continued
accelerating the car until they were hit
by a truck
although injured claire was alive until
holly stabbed her with a glass shard
right in the eye
claire's death was attributed to the
crash since then
holly has committed a series of gruesome
murders and written about them in her
journal
when seth realized the stories were real
he formulated a plan to save holly to
prevent her from hurting anyone else
claiming that he feels a purpose in his
life at the end
over the next several days they engage
in psychological mind games against each
other as holly begins to slip details to
draw seth in
seth insists that holly committed
another murder due to her unrevealed
guilt for claire's death
but she counters that she kills simply
because she enjoys it
he keeps thinking of other ways to save
holly until one day
his boss threatens to fire him because
his job is neglected
nate who becomes suspicious about seth
recently follows him and accidentally
discovers holly in the basement
he wants to rescue holly right away the
moment seth returns to the basement
holly deliberately distracts nate so
that seth has time to deal with him
reflexively seth hits nate's head with a
flashlight until he faints
holly urges him to kill nate using a
cinder block because she doesn't want
seth to be caught by the police
she guides a terrified seth to remove
traces of nate's death by dismembering
nate's body into pieces which will later
be used as dog food
scattering his teeth in different places
and burning his bones at the cremation
site
few days later the police become
suspicious of seth's role in nate's
disappearance
seth succeeds to escape with the help of
holly's word in answering the
detective's question day by day
seth feels all of holly's actions are
proof that holly sincerely loves him
holly convinces him to prove his love by
cutting off his finger
desperately seth does it right in front
of holly but this gives holly an
opportunity to take his knife and
threatening to kill herself if seth
doesn't want to release her
inevitably seth complies with her and
she says she finally believes that he
loves her before slitting his throat
after the shocking incident holly is
back together with eric
she finds another evidence that eric has
been cheating again however she declines
to hurt him
instead she travels to a warehouse where
it turns out that seth is being kept in
a cage
he is still alive but horribly mutilated
and tortured by holly she thanks him for
saving her by allowing her to take out
her murderous nature on him as a
substitute
showing the literal meaning of love is
blind subscribe to watch more videos
like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching